a 1.292 millones es el número de niños y
jóvenes fuera de la escuela detengámonos
por un segundo ante la magnitud de esta
cifra mil 292 millones es el 16 por
ciento de la población mundial actual
se calcula que en latinoamérica 160
millones de niños y jóvenes estarán en
sus casas este es el equivalente al 75
por ciento de la población de un país
como brasil que es el séptimo país en
población en el mundo
tienen acceso a algún tipo de educación
remota a través de cursos masivos en
línea de videoconferencias de recursos
en plataformas interactivas de
televisión y radio educativa incluso de
materiales impresos que en algunos casos
han llegado a sus casas
algunos no tienen acceso a educación
mi nombre es claudio rea soy educadora
de la invite y experta en educación y
tecnología y quiero hoy compartirles mi
idea de la educación imposible y es que
esta vida lo imposible tiene que ver con
el acceso a la mejor educación de
calidad para todos es una educación que
responde a las necesidades únicas del
individuo pero que además lo prepara
para que de forma colectiva pueda
resolver crisis como la que enfrentamos
hoy pero que además lo prepara para
inventar y crear mejor futuro para todos
y les hago una pregunta
levanten la mano si recuerdan por lo
menos una ocasión en la que alguien les
haya dicho que algo que quieren lograr
es imposible
50% 70% 90% creo que todos tenemos una
historia que contar y la que quiero
compartirles hoy tiene que ver con mi
proceso de admisión a posgrado en haití
que algunos pensaron imposible pero que
solo me tomó tres años en lograr y es
que esa idea lo imposible lo que desató
fue un deseo y una motivación para
seguir y continuar haciendo mi trabajo
mejor para llevar nuevas oportunidades
de aprendizaje aquellos que no tenían y
para repensar e inventar nuevas formas
de aprender
cuál sería nuestra realidad hoy sin la
bombilla eléctrica de edison y miles de
otras patentes que logró registrar en
los eeuu y en el mundo o nuestra vida
sin televisión que se ha convertido en
uno de los mecanismos de acceso a
educación para muchos niños del mundo
actualmente 78% de los hogares del mundo
tienen por lo menos una televisión
o que sería nuestra realidad sin los
numerosos intentos de los hermanos
wright por volar un avión
todas estas invenciones que en algún
momento se calificaron como pérdida de
tiempo imposibles pero regresemos
rápidamente a la crisis que nos reúne
hoy que ha sido posible ha sido posible
visualizar una capacidad increíble de
respuesta para dar acceso al aprendizaje
remoto a nuestros niños y jóvenes del
mundo esta capacidad de respuesta se ha
dado gracias a los avances tecnológicos
de los últimos años y me pregunto cuál
sería nuestra realidad y nuestro debate
si esta crisis hubiera pasado hace 50
años
ha sido posible derrumbar barreras que
por décadas han impedido que hagamos
avances y cambios significativos en la
educación y en nuestros sistemas
educativos del mundo ha sido posible
magnificar la capacidad de respuesta y
la cantidad de recursos existentes pero
ha sido posible de la misma manera
visualizar todas las deficiencias de
nuestro sistema y deben hablarles de
algunas de las prioridades que considero
se deben atender de forma inmediata la
primera tiene que ver con la dinámica en
el hogar alrededor de la educación de
los hijos la educación ya no es una
responsabilidad de la escuela se ha
convertido de forma inevitable en una
responsabilidad de la familia y el
individuo mismo tenemos que aprender y
crear estrategias para la construcción
de ese de ese desarrollo de aprendizaje
de nuestros niños
tenemos que dar acceso a los que no
tienen y cerrar brechas brechas de
acceso a tecnología pero también a
conocimiento y debemos por último
atender poblaciones vulnerables y deben
hablarles de dos de ellas la primera
población vulnerable de la que quiero
hablarles es de nuestra niñez en el
mundo en promedio el 50 por ciento de
los niños del mundo asisten a programas
preescolares antes de los 3 años en
latinoamérica el panorama es bastante
alentador el 75% de los niños tienen
acceso a este tipo de programas pero por
qué son importantes estos programas
porque el 80% del desarrollo del cerebro
sucede antes de los 3 años porque
tenemos evidencia de que el promedio de
escolaridad es un año más en niños que
han tenido este tipo de programas
comparados con niños que no han tenido
este tipo de programas y que en vida
adulta esos mismos niños tienen acceso a
mejores trabajos conservan sus trabajos
y han demostrado ingresos hasta de un 25
comparado con niños que no tienen acceso
esta es una población que nos está
costando atender en medio de esta crisis
a través de una educación remota con el
apoyo de las partes la segunda población
vulnerable son nuestras niñas y jóvenes
en el mundo nuevamente en latinoamérica
tenemos un panorama bastante alentador
donde en promedio un porcentaje mayor de
niñas termina su edad secundaria estas
niñas están en riesgo porque asumen en
medio de una crisis como la que estamos
viviendo actividades domésticas son las
que apoyan en la generación de ingresos
en la familia algunos de estos ejemplos
tienen que ver con sexo transaccional y
están en riesgo de ser víctimas de
abusos sexuales en su familia en sus
hogares que pueden resultar en embarazos
no deseados y que les va a impedir
regresar a sus escuelas
nuevamente una población que tenemos
urgencia de atender retomemos entonces
esta idea de la educación imposible una
educación para todos
donde la salud mental del estudiante de
sus familias y de los educadores es una
prioridad donde la tecnología magnifica
las capacidades del educador y el
sistema educativo donde se da respuesta
a las necesidades del individuo y además
se atiende con urgencia a las
poblaciones más vulnerables esta crisis
que no solamente es de salud pero es una
crisis del sistema educativo mundial
puede ser una oportunidad única para
crear una educación que parece imposible
pero cómo abordar este este reto de una
educación imposible para mí esta
educación imposible tiene que estar
apoyada por principios básicos del
liderazgo esta metáfora de la silla de
tres patas nos explica la manera más
sencilla los tres principios
fundamentales del liderazgo que empiezan
con las aspiraciones individuales y
colectivas que permite crear mecanismos
de reflexión para revisar nuestros
modelos mentales y los supuestos que
estamos haciendo con respecto a las
soluciones educativas que queremos crear
pero donde no perdemos la visión del
sistema como un todo creo que si algo
hemos aprendido en esta crisis
es que el beneficio de un individuo el
beneficio de una ciudad el beneficio de
un país no es suficiente para salir
adelante en una crisis
creo que esto mismo aplica en esta idea
de educación imposible
en medio de una crisis como la que
estamos viviendo actualmente algunos de
estos principios de liderazgo se
manifiestan en la forma de actuar de
nuestros gobernantes y generan
sentimientos de confianza y de esperanza
hacia una solución que va a llegar en el
futuro
los invito a que esto sea el sentimiento
de un movimiento que genere una
educación imposible y que el hacerlo
posible no nos impida lograr lo
imposible
[Música]